Générique
...
- Alexandre Poussart:
Bonjour à tous.
Bienvenue dans "Parlement hebdo".
On revient
sur les temps forts
de la semaine au Parlement.
- Kathia Gilder:
Pour commenter l'actualité,
nous accueillons
Jean-René Cazeneuve.
Il est député
Renaissance du Gers
et rapporteur général du budget.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Le projet de loi immigration
a été adopté
dans son ensemble par le Sénat.
On attend de voir
si Gérald Darmanin
va trouver une majorité
de députés
pour voter ce projet de loi.
- Kathia Gilder:
On parlera du marathon budgétaire
qui se poursuit au Sénat.
Le débat a été écourté
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Le Parlement doit
voter la loi
de finances avant la fin
de l'année.
La commission d'enquête
sur les groupuscules violents
a rendu son rapport
après six mois
de travaux.
Les députés
constatent une montée
de la violence
dans les manifestations
et des formes
d'action
de plus en plus radicales.
- Alexandre Poussart:
La majorité
de droite sénatoriale
a donc adopté
le projet de loi
immigration
dans une version durcie.
Le texte sera examiné
à l'Assemblée nationale
en décembre.
Pour le moment,
aucune majorité claire
ne se dessine pour le voter.
- Gérard Larcher:
Pour l'adoption: 210.
Contre: 115.
Le Sénat a donc adopté.
- Fumée blanche au palais
du Luxembourg mardi.
Le Sénat adopte le projet
de loi immigration
dans une version
fort durcie
par la majorité sénatoriale.
Droite et centre
se sont entendus
pour supprimer l'Aide
médicale d'Etat,
instaurer des quotas
d'immigration économique
ou interdire l'accès
aux allocations familiales
aux nouveaux arrivants
sur notre territoire
pendant 5 ans.
Surtout, l'article
3, qui prévoyait
la régularisation automatique
des travailleurs travaillant
dans les secteurs en tension,
a été supprimé.
Ce sera désormais au cas par cas.
- Jamais,
de mémoire de députés
ou de sénateurs LR,
nous n'avions été aussi fermes,
nous, la droite.
- A droite, la consigne
est claire: défendre
les apports du Sénat
lors de l'examen
du texte à l'Assemblée nationale.
Le but est de pousser
LR à voter
le texte sans braquer
l'aile gauche
de la macronie,
qui tient au rétablissement
de l'article 3.
- Ca va être compliqué.
Une partie
de mon groupe souhaite
un rétablissement du texte
dans sa version initiale.
Il y a le symbolique
article 3
qui a été vidé de sa substance.
Il y a beaucoup
de sujets sur lesquels
je suis en désaccord
avec les sénateurs.
- Un compromis autour d'une
nouvelle réécriture
de l'article 3,
à mi-chemin
entre les versions du Sénat
et du gouvernement,
pourrait servir
de terrain d'entente.
L'enjeu est d'éviter
un passage en force
et un recours au 49.3.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Vous pensez
qu'il y aura
une majorité pour voter
ce texte?
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
On va pas mettre
la charrue avant les boeufs.
Le Sénat a fait
son travail
et c'est très bien.
Certains
sénateurs
ne voulaient pas de texte
sur l'immigration.
On a déjà un texte.
Le Sénat a fait son travail.
C'est à l'Assemblée
nationale de faire
le sien.
C'est le principe du bicamérisme.
Je suis persuadé
que l'on arrivera
à un compromis
et à un texte qui trouvera
sa majorité.
En tout cas, je le souhaite.
Il faut le faire dans cet esprit.
On n'en est pas
encore au vote,
mais on est dans la phase
des postures politiques
qui précède les négociations.
On montre
les muscles, on dit
que ce n'est pas assez dur.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Il y a des postures politiques,
y compris dans la majorité
présidentielle,
à la gauche?
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
Chacun essaie
de pousser ses idées.
Il y a ceux qui disent
que le texte
est formidable,
et ceux qui veulent
le durcir ou qui n'en veulent pas.
- Kathia Gilder:
Il y a un article
au coeur
de ce projet de loi,
celui qui prévoit
la régularisation
des sans-papiers
dans les métiers dits
en tension.
Vous pensez
que l'Assemblée nationale
va rétablir cet article 3
dans sa forme initiale,
qui n'est pas celle qui a été
votée
par les sénateurs?
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
Il y a,
dans les modifications
faites
par le Sénat, des choses
qui nous paraissent intéressantes,
sur les visas étudiants,
les regroupements familiaux,
qui sont proposées.
La suppression de l'AME...
- Kathia Gilder:
Et sur la suppression
de la régularisation
des sans-papiers?
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
L'un des points forts
de ce texte,
c'est de reconnaître
qu'il y a des métiers
en tension,
qu'il y a des secteurs
qui ont besoin
de main-d'oeuvre.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous souhaitez
cette mesure, celle
de la régularisation
des sans-papiers?
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
On parle de 7000 personnes
par an.
Ce n'est pas une vague migratoire.
Je suis persuadé
que l'on peut trouver
une combinaison des idées
qui permette d'arriver
à un accord.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Un compromis
se dessine sur l'article 3?
- Jean-René
Cazeneuve:
Il faut pas
que ce soit complètement
discrétionnaire,
à la main du préfet.
Il faut peut-être que ce droit
opposable, aujourd'hui...
Les sénateurs souhaitent
que l'entreprise donne
son accord pour permettre
la régularisation.
- Kathia Gilder:
Les sénateurs LR
ont transformé l'Aide
médicale d'Etat
en une aide plutôt d'urgence
et en restreignant
le palier de soins
pour les étrangers
en situation irrégulière.
Est-ce que l'Assemblée
va revenir
sur ce vote du Sénat?
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
Je le souhaite.
- Kathia Gilder:
Ca coûte cher, l'AME.
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
Ca coûte 1 milliard
ou 1,2 milliard.
Si nous faisions le même
travail d'observation,
d'optimisation
de l'ensemble
de nos dépenses
que sur l'AME,
notre déficit serait
moins important qu'aujourd'hui.
Il y a eu beaucoup de rapports.
Pour les médecins,
c'est très difficile,
quand quelqu'un vient
dans votre cabinet
et que vous avez fait
le serment d'Hippocrate.
Vous ne pouvez pas renvoyer
les gens.
C'est aussi un problème
de santé publique.
Si vous ne soignez pas
ces gens
sur notre territoire,
vous risquez
une épidémie,
des maladies
qui ne sont plus chez nous...
Il faut maintenir
cette aide médicale.
En parallèle,
un rapport a été demandé
sur le sujet,
qui va être rendu
dans quelques jours.
On peut toujours optimiser.
- Kathia Gilder:
Et le tourisme médical?
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
Ca n'existe pas.
C'est un fantasme.
Il faut que l'on optimise
cette dépense.
Mais ça,
on sent bien
que c'est une posture politique.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Vous pensez
que les députés
Les Républicains,
dans les négociations,
pourraient abandonner
ce symbole politique
qu'ils arborent
sur l'AME?
- Jean-René
Cazeneuve:
Je ne peux pas répondre
à la place
des LR.
Ils sont nombreux
et ils ont des postures
très différentes sur le sujet.
Mais ce n'est pas dans le texte
initial.
Un des risques
pour LR,
c'est que ce dispositif
soit cavalier.
C'est important
d'être factuel
sur son intérêt,
sur ce qu'apporte
ce texte.
Pour moi, cette aide
est nécessaire.
C'est important
pour la santé publique.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous dites
que vous espérez
qu'un compromis
soit trouvé.
Si ce n'est pas le cas,
faute de majorité,
est-ce que le 49.3
vous semblera inévitable
pour faire passer cette loi?
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
Je ne le souhaite pas.
Je suis opposé
au 49.3 sur ce texte.
Utiliser le 49.3
sur les budgets,
c'est une chose.
Mais pour ce texte,
il nous faut
une majorité.
Il faudra que les LR
retournent
dans leurs circonscriptions
et expliquent pourquoi
ils sont contre un texte
qui durcit
la position
sur tous
ceux qui n'ont pas
leur place
dans notre pays.
Ce texte fait cela aussi.
Il facilite les procédures
sur les OQTF
ou sur les expulsions.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Les obligations
de quitter le territoire français.
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
Il va falloir
qu'ils expliquent
à leurs électeurs
qu'on va accélérer
ces dispositifs.
Il va falloir
qu'ils expliquent
que dans certains
métiers en tension,
on ne va pas régulariser,
même
sous conditions.
Ils vont devoir
expliquer pourquoi
ils sont contre.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Le gouvernement
a le droit d'utiliser
un seul 49.3
par session parlementaire.
Si on vous écoute,
ce texte immigration
n'est pas le bon
texte pour griller
ce 49.3?
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
Vous avez donné
une des explications.
La Première ministre est claire.
Je salue son engagement.
Elle trouve systématiquement
des majorités
sur les textes.
Elle y est arrivée
presque tout le temps,
à l'exception
des textes budgétaires
et à l'exception de la réforme
des retraites, évidemment.
Pour d'autres,
elle cherche des compromis.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Faute de compromis,
s'il n'y a pas de majorité
sur ce texte immigration,
est-ce qu'il faut griller ce 49.3?
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
Le coût politique
est trop important.
Après, on ne pourrait
plus utiliser
le 49.3
dans les six prochains mois.
Ca nous mettrait
en difficulté
dans les négociations
vis-à-vis
des autres partis politiques.
- Kathia Gilder:
On va suivre ce projet
de loi immigration
dans les prochains jours.
On va aussi vous parler du budget.
Vous êtes rapporteur
général du budget.
Les sénateurs
ont commencé à examiner
ce PLF.
A l'Assemblée,
le débat a tourné court.
On veut utiliser
l'article 49.3
pour faire passer ce budget.
- Du budget 2024,
on retiendra l'utilisation
du 49.3 rapidement.
- Le constat est clair.
Aucun groupe
d'opposition n'est prêt
à voter ce projet
de loi de finances.
Or, notre pays
a besoin de ce budget.
Aussi, sur le fondement
de l'article 49,
alinéa 3
et de la Constitution,
j'engage la responsabilité
de mon gouvernement.
- Le gouvernement
innove même en matière
de 49.3.
Je ne crois pas qu'on ait
déclenché
un 49.3
sur un budget avant même
de commencer l'examen
des articles.
- Dans ce budget,
le déficit sera ramené
à 4,4% du PIB en 2024,
avec l'objectif
de passer sous les 3% en 2027.
16 milliards d'euros d'économies
seront réalisées,
en partie avec la fin
du bouclier énergétique.
- Les oppositions
imaginent un monde
où tout est gratuit.
Le malheur
et la réalité,
c'est que tout coûte
quelque chose.
L'ère de l'argent
gratuit est finie.
Il serait temps
que les oppositions
s'en rendent compte.
Des amendements
dépensiers,
il en a plu comme à Gravelotte.
- La droite accuse
le gouvernement
de laisser filer les déficits.
La gauche regrette la fin
de mesures protectrices.
- Tous les signaux ont atteint
un seuil d'alerte inédit.
Il y a près
de 45.000 euros de dette
par Français.
- Le budget
proposé
ne suivra pas la hausse
de l'inflation.
La fin du bouclier
énergétique va aggraver
la situation de beaucoup.
- Après une adoption
par 49.3 à l'Assemblée,
le budget sera discuté
au Sénat à partir
du 23 novembre.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous êtes rapporteur général
du budget, Jean-René Cazeneuve.
Le débat a eu lieu
en commission,
mais pas en séance publique.
Il n'y a même pas eu un seul
article examiné.
Vous regrettez
qu'il n'y ait pas eu
un début de discussion?
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
Peut-être
une précision:
le débat a eu lieu
en commission.
Il y a eu une longue
journée de débats.
Il a eu lieu
sur la deuxième partie
du budget.
On a discuté dans l'hémicycle
des missions éducation,
outre-mer...
On y a passé une semaine.
Sur la partie 1,
la Première ministre
a tout de suite engagé
sa responsabilité.
Pourquoi?
Je respecte la position
des oppositions.
Il est de tradition,
dans notre pays,
que ce soit dans les exécutifs
régionaux, départementaux,
de ne pas voter le budget,
qui est l'acte politique
par excellence.
On passe notre temps
à nous reprocher
que l'on a trop de débats
qui ne servent
à rien.
Il y a deux dérives
dans notre débat politique,
aujourd'hui,
à l'Assemblée nationale,
que ne connaissent pas
encore les sénateurs.
C'est la multiplication
du nombre d'amendements.
On a multiplié par 7
le nombre d'amendements.
- Kathia Gilder:
Un chiffre
pour ce budget?
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
On est à 11.000 amendements
pour la partie 1 et 2.
Ensuite,
il y a une déresponsabilisation
d'un certain nombre
de partis politiques
sur les montants.
Il y a des amendements
à 12 milliards.
tellement importants
qu'ils vident
complètement les crédits.
Les amendements
des oppositions,
de La France Insoumise,
sont au-delà
du budget.
Il y a entre 400 et 500
milliards d'amendements
de LFI.
-
Alexandre Poussart:
Il n'aurait pas pu
y avoir des amendements
de l'opposition
plus raisonnables
qui auraient pu
être retenus à la fin
par le gouvernement?
- Jean-René
Cazeneuve:
C'est ce que l'on a fait.
L'un n'empêche pas l'autre.
Cela pose de vraies questions.
C'est le gouvernement,
avec un certain nombre
de ministères,
qui décide in fine
des amendements retenus.
Il y en a eu
un nombre important
qui ont été retenus.
Mais on est plus
dans le cadre
de ce débat...
C'est un peu le coût
de cette majorité relative.
Ces amendements embolisent
notre Assemblée.
- Kathia Gilder:
Il y a quand même
une mesure
qui a été discutée,
c'est la taxe
sur les super-dividendes.
Elle a été votée
et le gouvernement
ne l'a pas retenue.
Vous ne pensez pas qu'il aurait
pu faire
ce geste, cette mesure de justice?
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
Vous considérez
que c'est une mesure
de justice fiscale
et je considère
que c'est une hausse d'impôt
qui donne un signal
très mauvais
aux investisseurs.
Ce que fait notre majorité,
c'est rendre
notre pays attractif.
On recrée des emplois industriels.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous pensez
que ça aurait plombé
l'attractivité
de la France?
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
On est devenu
un pays où les investissements
étrangers
sont les plus importants
en Europe.
Ca crée des emplois.
Tout cela est basé
sur le fait
que nous baissons
les impôts
pour les entreprises.
Nous baissons
aussi les impôts
pour les particuliers
depuis 6 ans.
Il y a une vraie logique,
c'est la politique
de l'offre.
On est très attachés à cela,
à l'attractivité
de notre pays,
pour créer de la valeur
dans notre pays.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Quand on regarde
ce budget 2024,
il n'y a pas d'impôt
sur les super-dividendes
mais c'est aussi
la fin du bouclier énergétique.
Vous ne pensez pas
que les Français pensent
que c'est de l'injustice sociale?
On ne les accompagne
plus face à l'inflation.
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
Ca
n'est pas tout à fait vrai.
Il y a le bouclier énergétique
sur l'électricité
qui continue en 2024.
Les Français payent
leur électricité
à peu près un tiers
moins cher que s'il n'y
avait pas de bouclier.
Il y a une mesure
sur le carburant,
pour aider nos compatriotes.
- Alexandre Poussart:
C'est 100 euros
par an.
Ce sera moins.
- Jean-René Cazeneuve: Non.
Il y a encore des mesures
de soutien
que l'on a votées.
On augmente de 3,9
milliards d'euros
le budget de l'Education
nationale.
Pourquoi?
Parce qu'on augmente
les salaires
des enseignants et c'est normal.
Pourquoi notre budget
est important?
On augmente
les retraites,
tous les minima
sociaux,
toutes ces dépenses
sociales
qui sont indexées sur l'inflation.
Normalement, il n'y
a pas de perte
de pouvoir d'achat.
Les retraites augmentent
de la même manière
que l'inflation.
- Kathia Gilder:
Je voudrais parler
de la dette française.
Elle atteint
des niveaux record,
3000 milliards d'euros et plus.
Elle continue d'augmenter
de façon dangereuse,
au point que certains
organismes internationaux
comme le FMI mettent
en garde la France,
en prévoyant un plan
de rigueur à venir.
Vous prenez la menace au sérieux?
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
Je prends
la menace au sérieux, oui.
Ce n'est jamais bon.
Je disais tout à l'heure
que les oppositions,
y compris
celles qui nous accusent
de trop dépenser,
proposent des amendements
à plusieurs millions.
J'ai moi-même
proposé des baisses
de dépenses dans le budget.
Je n'ai pas amené de dépenses
supplémentaires.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Quelles économies
la France doit faire?
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
La dette coûte beaucoup d'argent.
Ceux qui nous ont expliqué
que ce
n'était pas grave
d'avoir une dette,
que ça ne servait à rien
de la rembourser,
ce n'est pas vrai.
Il y a les intérêts.
Nous faisons un budget
responsable.
Nous baissons le déficit
de 4,9% à 4,4.
C'est un effort de maîtrise
de nos dépenses publiques.
L'objectif est d'arriver
à 2,7% de déficit
en 2027.
C'est très important.
On le paye avec les intérêts.
Si, pour une raison
ou une autre,
notre note était dégradée
ou les taux augmentaient,
c'est tous les Français
qui paieraient.
Les taux d'intérêt
pour l'immobilier,
pour les entreprises,
ils augmenteraient.
- Kathia Gilder:
On va passer
à notre dernier thème.
Un cap supplémentaire
a été franchi
dans la violence.
C'est la conclusion
de la commission d'enquête
qui a travaillé
sur les groupuscules violents
et qui a rendu son rapport.
Les députés
ont fait la lumière
sur ces violences
qui ont eu lieu
pendant les manifestations,
notamment
pendant celles
contre la réforme
des retraites ou à Sainte-Soline.
Voici ce que dit
le président
de cette commission.
- Il y a un élargissement
de la violence.
Elle se diffuse
de plus en plus,
et surtout,
nos travaux le montrent,
elle est de plus
en plus légitimée,
y compris dans les discours
politiques.
Le fait, par exemple,
de ne pas dénoncer
cette violence,
est en soi déjà un problème.
Cette banalisation inquiète.
Les responsables
de manifestations devraient
avoir conscience
que quand on organise
une manifestation,
on doit tout mettre
en oeuvre
pour qu'elle se déroule
dans le calme.
- Kathia Gilder:
Les recommandations
de cette commission
d'enquête doivent figurer
dans une future loi
qui serait transpartisane.
Ce ne serait pas la première
loi anticasseurs.
Est-ce qu'une loi peut
vraiment endiguer
la montée de phénomènes
comme le décrit
le président de cette commission?
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
C'est nécessaire
et pas suffisant.
Je n'ai pas encore le détail
de ce rapport,
qui sera publié
dans les prochains jours,
mais cette montée
des violences,
c'est plus de 1500
gendarmes et policiers
qui ont été blessés
cette année
dans les manifestations.
C'est insupportable.
Les Français
le condamnent,
dans leur grande majorité.
C'est insupportable.
Il faut tenir compte
de ces recommandations
pour voir comment on peut
à la fois mieux encadrer
les manifestations,
les manifestants,
et mieux les condamner,
soit à titre individuel,
car quand on reçoit
les associations elles-mêmes
qui poussent à ce genre
de comportement...
Quand les Verts parlent
de transformer l'Assemblée
nationale en ZAD...
- Alexandre Poussart:
Certaines organisations politiques
ont-elles
une responsabilité
dans cette montée de la violence?
- Jean-René
Cazeneuve:
Elles ont une responsabilité
évidente
par leurs propos.
Elles cherchent le chaos.
Le droit
de manifester existe
dans notre pays.
On peut le faire.
Il y a eu une formidable
manifestation
contre l'antisémitisme,
dimanche dernier,
qui s'est fait dans le calme.
La France Insoumise,
aujourd'hui, pousse
au crime.
- Kathia Gilder:
La dissolution
des Soulèvements
de la Terre a été annulée
par le Conseil d'Etat
car elle a été jugée
disproportionnée.
Le gouvernement est-il
sorti de l'Etat
de droit en voulant dissoudre
les Soulèvements
de la Terre?
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
Le ministre
de l'Intérieur a tenté sa chance.
Cela a été retoqué,
c'est la preuve
que l'on est dans un Etat
de droit.
On va continuer à travailler,
peut-être modifier
la loi.
Il faut être sévère
avec ces associations
et ces individus
qui sont dans la violence,
qui veulent
déstabiliser et diviser
notre pays.
- Kathia Gilder:
Certains individus
et partis politiques
alimentent
ces mouvements?
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
On le voit
bien dans leurs propos.
Quand le responsable
d'un parti politique dit
que la police tue,
il alimente
cette violence
et ces conflits au sein
de la société.
Je voudrais profiter
de cette occasion
pour exprimer
ma solidarité vis-à-vis
des forces de l'ordre qui font
un travail formidable.
- Kathia Gilder:
Ce sera le mot
de la fin.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Merci
d'avoir été avec nous.
Merci de nous avoir suivis.
A la semaine prochaine.
SOUS-TITRAGE LIVE: RED BEE MEDIA